Okay. Well, welcome everybody.
We were expecting a much bigger crowd, but thank you for coming who did come.
So today, we're going to talk about MAIVS, or multiplex
assays of variant effects, as they apply to cancer predisposition
genes. And at least the examples I'll give will
be from the breast cancer, ovarian cancer predisposition genes, and
then Jacob Kitzman, who's joining me here today,
will talk more about the colorectal and some other angles.
So here are the two presentations.
Originally, we were going to have Leah Starita from the University of Washington
join us, but she had to pull out. So we'll just spend a little bit more time on
our two talks, 30 minutes each,
as we walk through the principles of MAIVS and then some
of the discoveries that have been made in recent times.
Okay.
Okay, so I'll start with my presentation.
I'm going to be talking about some of the work that we've done on BRCA2,
the breast and ovarian cancer predisposition gene,
and then talk about how we might combine MAIVS together.
So as more and more of these types of studies are starting to get published and
data coming out,
we're finding multiple different experiments done on the same gene.
The hypothesis is that there's benefit to putting these things together.
They may actually improve the
accuracy of some of our measures.
So I want to talk a little bit about
that work and ways that you might approach putting the data sets together.
Okay. So here are my financial disclosures.
Okay, so let me just introduce you to some breast cancer genes.
What we're looking at on the x-axis is just the frequency in the population.
So most of these are fairly rare. BRCA1 and BRCA2
mutations are probably found in the population at about one in 300.
And then the effect size, how high is the risk?
So you can see BRCA1 and 2 up here as high-risk genes, as I said, are
reasonably rare, but there's a lot of other low-risk or moderate-risk
genes
that are listed on the diagram here.
So there's plenty of genes for us to play with.
In the breast cancer field, we think of maybe 10 or 12 genes that
meet those criteria that are actually driving breast cancer.
So if we wanted to do MAIVS on all of these, that's a fair amount of work.
But as you'll see as I go through the presentation, quite a few of these have
already been attempted.
So as we do a lot of clinical genetic testing on all these
various genes, we find a lot of variants of uncertain significance, and this is
probably a term that many of you will have come across already.
So essentially when we do genetic testing, the idea is can we find a known
pathogenic variant that will inform the care of the patient?
But many times we actually find these variants of uncertain significance, and these
tend to be missenses around intronic or in-frame deletions or
insertions. We don't know what they do.
And as a result, the patients do not benefit from the clinical
modification, the clinical management strategies that we can apply when we
know that there's a pathogenic variant in the particular gene.
And so these are listed out here. And in breast cancer, we often think of
things like enhanced screening with MRIs and mammograms.
And we can also do prophylactic surgery.
So there are reasons why it's important to figure out what these VUS are
doing. Currently, clinically, if you find a VUS, the
genetic test is essentially thrown away, and you have to focus on
managing the patient based on their personal and their family history of the
disease. Okay?
So there's thousands of these things out there.
If you look at some of the bigger genes in breast cancer, BRCA1, BRCA2, PALB2,
ATM, these are all quite large genes.
There are thousands of VUS that are in the ClinVar database that
remain unresolved. And so this is the purpose of MAIVS and the application of
MAIVS to this set of genes is to figure out what all these things do.
Can we convert them from unknown or uncertain over to either
benign or pathogenic? That's the concept.
And of course, MAIVS are ideal for this kind of thing because we can do large
multiplexed assays, and this is just a general diagram where we
can select a model system, a cell type that we want to use for a
culture.
We can make many, many different mutants and put them all in the cells together,
hopefully one per cell.
And then we essentially apply a selection process that could be
viability, it could be a response to a challenge like a
DNA-damaging agent or something like that.
There's many different ways of doing that.
Obviously, you have to know your disease, and you have to know your gene in order
to select those processes.
But once you've done that, this is where the MAIV technology comes in, is that
we can just harvest DNA out of all of these cells all at the same time,
amplify up the little regions of interest, and sequence them.
Sequence them super deep, hundreds of millions of reads.
And from that, you can do the number of counts of each variant
in the final data set. Right? And so by
comparing counts at early time points and late time points, there's other ways to
do it, but if you just do it that way, you actually end up with a simple functional
score. It's a ratio of, let's say,
day one to day five, or day five to day 15, that sort of idea.
You can actually ratio the data and get a functional score.
So let me give you the example of BRCA2.
I'll just walk through some of the data that we published last year on this topic.
So BRCA2 is a well-known predisposition gene for breast and ovarian cancer.
It's involved in homologous recombination DNA repair, so generally
double-strand breaks or replication fork issues.We know
that if you have a protein-truncating mutation in BRCA2, which is what we
call a pathogenic variant, we're at about a 69% lifetime risk of breast
cancer and about a 15% lifetime risk of ovarian.
And there's a few other cancers that come along for the ride as well, as shown
here. Here's the gene down below or the
protein, and we focus here, the red box is on the DNA binding domain.
And the MAVS that have been done so far on BRCA2 have all
really focused on this region. You might say, "Well, why?
Why only that piece?" Well, it's because all the known
pathogenic missense variants, single amino acid changes that are known
clinically, are all in this region.
There essentially are no others that are known.
There are a few sprinkled around that are splice variants that result in
truncation of the protein. But if you're just talking about a true
missense, they're all in this DNA binding domain.
So these large functional screens have focused in on that region as a
result.
So here's the schematic of the actual experiment.
First thing I'll tell you is that we're using HAP1 cells.
These are haploid,
so that means they've got one copy of each chromosome.
That's ideal for a MAVE targeting type experiment where you're trying to knock in
all these mutations. Now you only have to target the cell one time.
You only have to get it into one chromosome.
If that was a diploid cell, you have to get it into both.
So it's so much easier with a haploid line.
The caveat to that is that you don't always know that this haploid cell is
behaving the right way. Is it behaving the same as a diploid cell?
But it's a starting point, and so many of the experiments that have been
done for at least cancer genes have focused on the
HAP1 cells. And the original use of that was the Nature 2018
paper from Findlay, where they studied BRCA1 and reported that out, and then we
did the same thing for BRCA2 last year.
Here's the DNA binding domain up above.
You can see our little molecular scissors here.
Each exon is done in its own experiment, so one exon at a time,
and obviously in triplicate.
And then we basically rely on viability.
So if you take out a homologous recombination gene out of the HAP1 cells,
they will start to die. It's a basic viability effect.
And so what we do is we harvest cells at day five, where we've
integrated all the mutations. We've put them into the endogenous
locus, into the actual genome of the cells,
and then we wait until day 14. And if it's a nasty mutation, they've been
dying at day 14.
If it's a wild-type variant, they've been growing.
And so you can make these ratios when you sequence of day 5 to day 14.
Is it going up or down?
That results in a functional score, which can be plotted out as a diagram like
this.
So here's what the data looks like.
Here's your functional score of that ratio that I was mentioning.
And you see a nice separation of your nonsense variants and your synonymous
variants.
And of course, this is ideal for all MAVEs that you would do for any disease
state or for any gene that you would want to study. You need standards.
You need known pathogenics and known benigns.
And that's where it becomes more difficult, I think, for some diseases where we
don't have many of those controls. We don't really know what to use as controls.
But in the context of BRCA2, where it's been studied a lot, there's lots and lots
of these controls available. So there's a very nice separation between those two
peaks. And then you see all the other types of variants.
In green are the missenses. There's thousands of them in here,
all evaluated in the same basic experiment.
We've pooled all the data together and normalized across all the exons.
So it's all one experiment, essentially.
Now, how do you analyze the data? Okay, you've got this ratio, but how do you now
align it all and come up with probability models
or classification models based on that function?
There's lots of different ways to do that.
There are programs out there such as Enrich 2, which you can just put your data in
there, and it does it on the basis of a simple precision model or a
two-component mixture model. In other words, it's basically saying, I know where
my two sets of standards are. I can model a two-component Gaussian
curve on that and make a binary cut point to say,
left of that is bad, right of that is good. That sort of idea.
That's a simplistic model, but it is what people were originally doing.
You can also go to 95% probability or precision models.
So only the things that are in the top 5% on the benign or the
pathogenic, or the non-functional and the functional sites would be picked as the
nasty ones. Everything that fell in between that still sits there as
VUS.
And then there's also the idea of a continuous probability
model all the way from one to 100. And so every variant gets its
own probability, its own score, and then you have to figure out how do
you make thresholds or cut points in that experiment.
We actually went beyond that, and we actually used what's called VarCall.
So this is a model that was developed by Ed Iverson at Duke University
a number of years ago, and it's essentially a two-component Gaussian model based on
two sets of standards, but it allows for
probabilities based on replicates and batch effects.
It accommodates all of that.
So you actually give it a prior probability.
So we use alpha missense. If you apply alpha missense to all these missenses, alpha
missense predicted that 20% would be deleterious or
non-functional. So we give it a prior of 0.2.
And then we roll all the functional data in on top to give a posterior
probability.
One of the advantages of VarCall is it rolls the data out into seven different
variant categories. So these are pathogenic strong, pathogenic
moderate, pathogenic supporting, VUS, and then the same
three categories for the strongs.
Now, some of these categories might be reminiscent to you in that
they are actually the seven categories that we use in the
ACMG, so the ClinGen ACMG classification
models that are now widely used for disease genes.
It's the same seven categories.So essentially what we've done with the
functional data is we've calibrated it to the ACMG classification
model so that the data can be directly added into that classification
model. Some other functional assays, as I said, just have binary, so
two regions, two groups, or three groups.
How do you integrate that data into the ACMG models?
That's a challenge, right? But with this, it's just easier because you already have
the seven categories up front.
Okay, so back to the data itself. Here's your seven categories with the color
key. Here's the different types of variants.
You can see that all the nonsenses are pathogenic strongs, high strong,
high probability of being pathogenic, so that makes perfect sense.
You're truncating the protein. All the synonymous, so single amino
acid,
nucleotide changes that don't change the amino acid.
The vast majority of those are actually benign strong.
That makes sense as well. And then about 13% to
14% of the missenses look like they're pathogenic strongs.
And if you look over here, that's a busy table.
I'm only going to focus on one number, which is that how many of the missenses are
in the pathogenic strong category?
The answer is 502, which is about 10%, 11% of all the
missense variants.
That's a huge number because if you go into ClinVar today, you only find about
30 to 50 missense variants that are considered pathogenic strong or
likely pathogenic.
Here, there's 500 in this assay. Okay?
But again, this is function. This is not clinical classification.
That's the difference. So keep in mind, this is still only function.
Now, one of the major important things with a MAVE, when you do a MAVE, is what's
the performance of your MAVE to known standards?
And I mentioned that we model the data on standards, but we still have to
assess the performance on standards.
So we actually, with BRCA2, were able to come up with a series of different
standards. These are known pathogenics in ClinVar, in the ClinVar
database, all the way down to a different DNA repair assay that we
do in our lab, and we've published hundreds of variants using this assay.
So we had different metrics that we could actually use to assess the sensitivity
and specificity so that the data wasn't circular. Right?
You want it to be independent of how you originally trained the model.
And if you look over here at the sensitivity and specificity, we're above 93% to
95% in all of those categories. So it really does
look like the MAVE worked really quite well and matches up with what's known about
this protein and this gene.
One take home message here, however, is that MAVEs are not perfect.
There is error in MAVEs, and you can see that there's a few percent that are
differential, that are wrong,
and that makes sense. We expect that in a biological system.
Perhaps more replicates would have fixed that.
Addition of other data might fix that.
But certainly there's more work to be done to sort that out.
Now that we've done a functional assay and we can calibrate all these data and
look at all these variants, the next question is, well, is it actually clinically
meaningful?
So one way to do that was to look at risk, simple risk.
So this is a case-control association study.
This is data provided to us by clinical collaborators.
This is Ambry Genetics in particular.
And we were able to take all the variants like these pstrongs, all those missenses
that were pstrong in the prior slide that I showed you, and run them through a
case-control association study, and you get 4.5.
Truncating mutations are coming in around 5.5.
So okay, they're a little bit different, but the confidence intervals overlap, so
we can't actually say that they're different.
But the important take home message here is that as a pool, all
these pstrong variants are high risk.
They definitely increase the risk of breast and ovarian cancer, as you can see down
below. So this sort of confirms that the assay, on a
global level at least, is giving us the right results.
It's matching up with the clinical phenotypes.
This is just relating back to the ACMG model.
We wanted to then-- the other way of looking at this clinically is can you run them
through ClinGen ACMG models and classify them as
pathogenic or likely pathogenic or benign, likely benign?
So that's really the goal. For a clinician to be able to use the data, you have to
get to that point. So this is sort of the ACMG model that we
use. There are two what we call VCEPs, variant curation
expert panels, that have been set up. One is for BRCA one and two.
Another is for all the other predisposition genes for breast,
ovarian, and pancreatic. And those two groups work on trying to
classify variants with all these different measures.
And you can see them listed out down below, in silico predictions,
case-control data, functional data is in there, et
cetera. You can combine them all together with a series of points to come up with
classifications.
And that's what this Sankey plot actually is
or this alluvial plot as some people like to call it. What are you looking at?
It's a very busy slide, but basically it's the five different types of variants
on the vertical axis there, and then all the little functional categories that we
have within each type of variant. So pathogenic strongs, the benign
strongs, the seven categories in each group.
And then having taken that function, we integrate it with all the other data in the
ACMG model, and here's your final ACMG classification.
You can see they break down into those five categories that I mentioned, the likely
benigns and benigns, the likely pathogenics and pathogenics,
and then the VUS in the middle. And so starting with 7,000 variants,
we end up with only 608 that remain as VUS
in this experiment.
So you've taken care of over 90% of your variants.
So this is the beauty of all these models. They connect together now.
You go from this large functional screen all the way to clinical
classification in one swath.
So that's BRCA2. You can see how effective that looks.
It's really quite impressive how it worked out.
But MAVEs have been done now for some of these other genes that I mentioned at the
beginning. BRCA1 was done years ago, as I said.
There's been some follow-up studies on that.
There's a
meta archive paper
from a group in the UKWhere instead of doing it in Hap1s, they
now did it in primary mammary epithelial cells.
So these are cells from the breast rather than a Hap1 cell, which is actually a
human leukemia line.
So if you're going to study the effect on breast and ovarian cancer, maybe you need
to be using the right cell type. That was the rationale behind their study.
And they actually found a lot of discrepancies in their results for HMX
versus Hap1s. And I think the jury's still out on what that means
and how to integrate those two results together.
We're still thinking about that. But there may need to be
recalibration of functional assays.
It could be that the whole register is just off,
and maybe they just shift relative to one another.
The efficacy within one cell type could be different to the other, but as long as
it's proportional, maybe it's reading out the same result.
That's to be determined. BRCA2, as I just showed you,
about 14% were non-functional.
PALB2 was recently published in "Nature Communications."
Only 5% are pathogenic, likely pathogenic in that setting,
40% intermediate. So a lot to be done there really to resolve some of
that.
ATM was published in early 2025 by a group from South Korea.
All 63 exons, a monumental amount of work really to get through that
gene.
But they actually found about 23%, 25% of the missense
variants looked like they were knocking out activity.
And then finally, CHEK2 has been published as a series of yeast viability screens.
There's some human studies that are underway right now, but they're not published
yet. But the yeast viability screens are suggesting maybe
15% of the missenses are pathogenic.
So I think you can see here that every gene is different, right?
These numbers are bouncing around from 5% up to 25% in terms of
how many missenses would be pathogenic.
And a number of years ago, there was a few publications and white papers
suggesting that maybe only 2% to 5% of all VUS would be pathogenic.
It's clearly not true. You can see from the data here that there can
be very, very high loads of pathogenicity in some of these genes, up to
25%.
So let's now talk, just in the last couple of minutes, let's talk about
combining
MAIVs. So as I mentioned, now as more and more work is being done in this
field, we're finding two or three or four MAIVs in
different genes. How can we put those together?
Well, there's a couple of different models here, right?
We have to think about what it actually means when we do two
MAIVs. Are they two MAIVs for exactly the same
function? So like BRCA2, let's say a DNA repair assay.
So were two MAIVs done, both measuring DNA repair activity in
BRCA2? If that's true, then you could probably combine the data at a
fairly elemental level.
But if it's two MAIVs done under totally different conditions,
so you might have added a drug on one or given a different dose of drug or
done different time points, you've got to think carefully about what the results
mean. You can't just throw them together, I think.
We really have to calibrate those data relative to one another.
What happens if they're in different cell types?
I mentioned the BRCA1 result that's in MedArchive.
That's really confusing, the result that they've produced to this point.
And we need to think about that.
I think most of us would agree that there could definitely be splicing differences
and protein stability differences in different cell types.
So that might be one of the underlying reasons why there are differences, but there
may be others.
And then if you're measuring totally different functions, that could be problematic
as well.
And so,
in a setting where you have totally different functions or totally different cell
types, you really do have to be careful.
And in that situation, we may not want to do a combination of the MAIVs.
We really may want to treat them as completely independent and never merge them
because they're really measuring totally different things. Okay?
Just keep that in mind. It's always a warning sign
associated with some of these things.
So there was a nice paper
published here by Calhoun. Well, he's not published yet.
It's again, in the archives from Calhoun.
This is a white paper from the
AIV group or the MAIV group. There's a sort of a consortium been put together
to look at MAIVs.
And they came up with a series of steps that you should
consider if you're going to put these combinations of these things
together.
So one, of course, is to map them onto the same transcript of the gene.
I think that's just sensible, right?
You're looking at the same-- It's not apples and oranges.
They are actually the same coding regions.
Use only commonly evaluated variants.
Now, that's an interesting idea, right?
So if you restrict to only the variants that are done in both of the MAIVs,
what are you losing there? Are you leaving out a lot of data?
And I'll show you an example for BRCA2 in a few minutes where that actually becomes
quite important.
Should you be allowing for the missing data in some way?
Consider excluding candidate splicing variants.
Some of these assays are done with cDNAs.
Some of them are deep into the introns.
Some don't have any introns at all, right?
So you may have differences in the MAIVs in terms of the ability to catch splicing
effects in canonical splice sites.
And then can you take the data and transform it and rescale
it so that the two experiments are actually on the same basic footprint,
so that you could actually combine the data a little bit better?
So all of these fairly detailed--
people can make assumptions about this stuff, but I think we really have to
evaluate them very carefully before we put data together.
And in that white paper then, they just went through a whole-- I encourage you all
to go read it. As I said, it's in the archives.
It's really worth a read if you're interested in this field.
But they
walk through a series of different potential models for combining the data
together,
and for reevaluating the performance.
And they do come back then with one example, which is p53, the
TP53 gene. And they basically take data from
four different functional screens of p53, and they put it all
together.And interestingly, the model that wins in the end was
a random forest.
So basically, it's a probability-based model.
They put all the data in together, and the model sort of figures out what is the
right combination. But it was vastly superior to the other methods.
As you can see here, this sort of teal-colored peak.
And so that was their final take-home message is that
a combined MAIV of four different assays using a random
forest was really the right way to go for P53.
So that's a success story. That was a great example, but what about other genes?
So I want to tell you a little bit about a study we just published on
BRCA2, where we did try to do something similar.
So just to give you some background on the two MAIV experiments I'm talking about,
one is the experiment I mentioned that I just described for BRCA2,
which is our own study in the human HAP1 line.
And then the other was actually in mouse embryonic stem cells done
by Shime Sharan at the NCI.
Again, using a viability assay. So at least we were using the same basic readout,
which was viability, but two totally different cell types.
Very similar coverage, but there were some differences.
And if you look at our assay relative to standards, we were at 93%
sensitivity and 95% specificity relative to the known standards.
They were just a little bit lower. But in general, the performance of the two
assays were similar. Okay? So then the question was: Could we
combine the data?
So the way we went ahead was four different models.
We wanted to assess really all possible approaches here.
So one was just what I call a concordance model that anybody in
this room could do. Take the two data sets,
slam them together, and just take the variants that are commonly assessed
by both methods and see if there's consistency.
So just look for the consistency.
Did both assays show it as a benign effect?
Did both assays show it as a non-functional effect, right?
That's a fairly easy result.
And then only classify the variants that have concordance.
If something is discordant between two assays, you throw it away because you don't
know who has the right answer. Okay?
So in this concordance model for BRCA2, we end up only evaluating
80% of the variants. We lose 20% because of all these caveats that I
just explained to you. They end up getting dropped out.
And that's a problem, right? Because when you're trying to address all possible
variants for clinical purposes, you really want to do as close to
100% as possible. Losing 20% of the variants is really not
a good thing.
The other way we did it was we actually, because the two assays were very similar
and they were looking at viability,
we were able to actually scale the two experiments together and then take their raw
data and our raw data and put it together
and treat it all as raw data. So we ended up with five experimental points from the
two combined assays, and then we ran our VarCall model.
So that's what we call the integrated model.
You're actually using the raw data from both experiments to look at consistency.
And that ends up doing the vast majority of the variants.
It's something like 94%, 95% of the variants get captured in that experiment.
And then these other ones are just other models. That's a VarCall experiment.
There's another method called GMM, which is another way of just analyzing the data
by probability, and then concordance of the GMM and the
VarCalls, right? So we're just looking at four different methods.
And here's sort of a busy
slide here, but let me point out that the one on the left is based on ClinVar.
So there's a number of known pathogenic and known benign variants in ClinVar.
We use those as standards to evaluate these four models.
And then the other one was this homologous recombination DNA repair assay that I
mentioned earlier
that we've done as a standalone
study, and we'd done enough variants in there that we could use them as
standards in this assay, right? And so when you line them all up, what you're
looking for is how well does the integrated VarCall model do?
You can see them here.
There are some peaks that are higher, but no model really does better
in terms of getting the two peaks close together.
You want both sensitivity and specificity to be working well here.
Specificity being
false positives, right? So if you have a benign variant and you mistakenly
call it a pathogenic variant, that's a real problem in the clinical world
because now you're potentially telling a patient that they have a pathogenic
variant when in fact they don't.
So in clinical assays, the specificity is oftentimes more
important than the sensitivity for that very reason.
You don't want to make a mistake. Okay?
So that's why we want both peaks close together.
In the HR standards, we see a better separation.
You can see that the consistency there for the integrated model looks better.
So we ended up landing on the integrated model and said that was the best approach.
And then this is that Sankey plot where we look at the types of variants,
we look at the results of the functional integrated model, and then we go all the
way to ACMG classification again, as I showed before.
What do you end up with this time? Now we have 396
that are VUS.
So
we're still measuring over 95% of all the variants, and yet
our VUS rate has dropped down to 396, whereas before it was
over 500.
So we did tighten up the data, it did clean the data, and it
resolved more of the variants at the same time.
So the take-home message here is that the combined data set is
better than any individual data set, as you might expect, but it's
nice to see the proof on the page here.
And then to just verify that at the clinical level, we did the case-control
risk analysis again. And sure enough, you can see the peaks here or
the dots here on the
plot here. You're seeing that these pathogenic strong variants from the
combined model are behaving just like the protein-truncating
variants. So everything was working fine in that
regard.I will say, however, that there are other
functional assays out there. I've just showed you the results for two big
MAVEs, but there's other assays that I won't get into in detail,
but these are much smaller. They've only done a few hundred at a time.
But they're still valuable data, and we'd like to be able to use them.
And so there's a presentation tomorrow from Alvaro Monteiro that I encourage you to
look at, where he actually talks about the integration of huge numbers of
functional assays for both BRCA1 and two, and how you can put all the data
together from many different types of assays, not just from MAVEs.
Okay, so if you're interested, I encourage you to go attend that.
So let me give a summary here.
So MAVEs are wonderful for providing detailed functional data for many
variants. Functional data, okay?
But then you can integrate the data into the ClinGen ACMG
models, as I showed you.
And that's proven very effective for reclassification of, in
our assay at least, over 95% of the VUS in the
region of interest.
And that's the result there. So where
multiple MAVEs do exist, a variety of methods
for combining the MAVEs can be used.
I just gave you one example. We saw the P53 example, we saw the
BRCA2 example. There's many other ways of doing it.
Every combined MAVE
experiment is just going to be totally different.
It's going to be unique, and you try to put those together as best you can,
but you have to know something about your disease and your gene.
The P53 approach was really interesting to see
how that worked out so well with a random forest model.
I told you about the two MAVE studies.
And then the take home message from all of this is that combining MAVEs, individual
MAVEs and combining MAVEs, are really expected to have
dramatic
impacts on improved diagnostics and risk assessment for patients.
And that's what it's all about. It's about the patients in the end.
It's not just a genetics exercise. There's a purpose behind this.
So,
I will stop there, and I will happily take some questions for a few minutes before
I hand over to Jacob.
Good, we have one customer.
Hi, Dr. Couch.
I'm actually very familiar with your work. I'm a new postdoc in Alvaro's lab.
Thank you.
So I'm familiar.
I had a question about
BRCA in terms of the assays you're testing.
So there's
more recent work over the last, well, six-ish years about its
sensitivity,
or hypersensitivity is more due to single-strand gaps-
Yeah
... other than, say, HDR. So I'm curious if that's something you guys have thought
about testing these variants in terms of the numbers.
Yeah. And there's another paper that has come out related to what you're just
saying. There's a paper came out from Katerina Schlacker at MD Anderson
showing replication fork effects, which is kind of related to what you're talking
about there.
In her paper, she shows one particular variant way down
at the C terminus of BRCA2 that is outside this DNA-binding domain that has
separation of function. It impacts replication forks but doesn't impact
homologous recombination repair.
But it obviously brings up the question of whether all of these
variants are impacting replication stress as well
as double-strand break repair, right? And so that has to be evaluated.
So we're trying to build assays now that would measure that.
There's a sort of a colorimetric
assay that potentially could be used to do that in a high-throughput method.
So it's definitely a question, and it relates to some of the things I talked about,
which is that,
are you measuring two different functions? Are you really measuring just one?
It's really quite important to be certain that you're focusing on one
outcome.
Thank you.
Okay.
Can I have a very short,
not question, but I'm doing some clinical
interpretation. So I was amazed with the
proportion of what we thought to be benign that
is probably not benign, and we're reporting them as benign,
whereas we shouldn't. 23, 25% of them could
be actually functionally impaired.
Is-
Well, we're not calling them benign. We're calling them VUS.
Right.
Right. Which is a very different thing, right?
But they are not called at all, right?
So we-
That's true. You're not doing anything with them genetically.
Typically, we don't really report them, so-
Right
... this is disturbing.
Yes. And so in countries and companies
that have not reported out the VUS,
it raises a question of how many variants have they left behind and missed
because they didn't report the information.
Absolutely. But the clinicians don't want them in the report.
They say, "No," they get-
They don't want them because-
... confuse the patient.
Well, in fairness to the clinicians, they didn't want them because they didn't know
what to do with them.
Exactly.
They couldn't do anything with them.
Now with these large MAVE studies, I think we're getting to the point.
I'm not saying we're there today, but we're very close to being able
to say a lot about most of these variants.
Amazing. Very good work.
Thank you.
Hello. My name is Tarun. I sort of have an opposite kind
of interpretation. So I got my genome done a couple of months
ago, and I have a BRCA2 pathogenic mutation,
but I don't have any phenotype. How do we evaluate these
ClinVar classifications versus
whatever MAVEs tell us?
Right. So if you
have a BRCA2 pathogenic variant already
diagnosed, right, then the MAVE isn't going to tell you any more.
You already know the result for your variant, right? You already know your result.
But I don't think I have a phenotype for BRCA2,
right?
So how do we evaluate this ClinVar versus MAVE versus
whatever reports tell us?
Well,
what we do with most of this genetic information is just predict risks.
So we're predicting
on a population base what the risk is.
So there are 80-year-old people who never developed cancer with a
BRCA2 mutation or a BRCA1 mutation.
But there are other people at the age of 20 who got it.
So it is a population level of risk that you're getting.
It's not personalized risk per se.
So the MAVE really doesn't address that at all.
That's more of a polygenic risk score sort of question.
It's a little bit different. So I don't think the MAVEs can answer that.
The MAVEs are only good for taking variants that we don't know anything about
and at least putting them into some sort of classification.
Are you classifying yourself or are you using databases like
ClinGen, ClinVar for these classifications?
Well, we compare to that for sure, but we're using our own data for the
classification purposes. Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I had a couple of questions.
Sure.
Thanks, by the way, for the great talk.
One, you talked about some recalibration necessary to
interpret what could be happening in the tissues.
Yeah.
Could you speak a little bit to what the state-of-the-art is over there?
And I was also wondering about MAVEs for non-coding variants.
Okay.
To be honest, I'm not aware of really a lot of information
about recalibrating the two different tissue types.
These data are really new for BRCA1.
We don't know what it looks like in other
tissue types. We don't know what some of these other genes,
PALB2, BRCA2, we don't know what they look like in different tissue types.
I think we have to do these experiments and gather more information.
I think combining it with the clinical phenotypes in large data sets.
We can look at all of us, we can look at UK Biobank for these types of things, but
we can also look in data sets from some of the large testing companies that
might inform the phenotypes a little bit and tell us what's real and what's not
real.
It could be that in one cell type, a mutation's
pathogenic, in another, it's an intermediate sort of hypomorph.
We could be seeing these types of differences. We don't know yet.
And it's really a black box at this time. It's so early.
We don't have a good understanding of it.
And then the second question was non-coding region? Yeah.
So
some groups have looked at that. In our experiment, I didn't get into it in any
detail, but we put in 10 bases on each side of the canonical
splice site. So we had at least 10 bases of intron,
which was informative. There's quite a lot of variants in there that do seem to
knock out activity.
So they result in cell death in the haploid cells, suggesting to us that they're
altering splicing in some way,
and leading to protein truncating effects.
But there's other MAVEs that don't measure that.
And Jacob will talk about cDNA-based studies which can't measure that either.
So
again, we don't have a lot of data. We only have a couple of MAVEs for each of
these genes so far. I think there's still a lot of work that needs to be done to
address. That could be a whole separate line of inquiry,
really, to focus in on deep intronic, near intronic, and
deep intronic variants to try and resolve some of that.
Jacob, you have a comment or a question?
You have a question, actually. Really great talk.
I'm curious about, you mentioned polygenic risk, and I know there's some excitement
in combining that with rare variant.
And so is this something you've looked at?
And what would be sort of the framework for integrating these?
We have not looked at it yet. It's simply an idea on a piece of paper.
But it's obviously where we're going to go.
As polygenic risk scores come into clinical
utility, there's still some debate on that, but I think it is going to happen,
especially for breast cancer.
We'll be looking at how PRS modifies different mutations, different
pathogenic variants, and then obviously how it modifies missenses that might come
out of MAVEs as well. So integration of more and more data to
improve. That will lead to the personalized risk, I think a little bit more
than just a straight MAVE. So we're going the right direction with that.
Okay.
Yeah, one more question.
Very nice presentation.
Actually, I'm new to the field. I just have a very simple question with
regard to the splicing variants.
Like when mapping the MAVEs into the common transcript,
what is the rationale behind excluding splicing variants?
Is it because
our assays do not capture the splicing effects, or what is it exactly?
Yeah. So the issue there is that
if a missense variant, not in a canonical splice site or in an intron, but if
it's deep inside an exon,
and it's predicted to be a splicing variant, like a cryptic splice site,
then if it is splicing, then it's going to kill the cells.
It's going to cause a protein truncating mutation. It's going to kill the cells.
In the MAVE, that reads out as a viability effect.
It reads out as it's killing. But you don't want to make the
mistake of thinking that that's because of the basic function of the variant.
It's actually because of the splicing of the variant.
Now, you might say that's semantics. It doesn't really matter how it's killing it.
The point is it's killing it. But I think we have to validate some of these things.
So one thing you'll have noticed as I went through all of this is that there's no
mention of any RNA work.
Nobody's done an RNA screen as a MAVE yet.
Credit to Lea Starita and Greg Finley for the BRCA1 paper back in
2018. They did a huge amount of RT-PCR on the same
cells that they did the DNA work on.
To the best of my knowledge, nobody's done that since.
It's just such a huge amount of work that everybody's just focused on getting the
DNA results first and the basic viability, and now we all have to go
back and redo all these RNA things.
And then there's a lot of people actually trying to do long-readRNA work right now
trying to resolve the impacts of some of these variants on
transcripts. But
yeah, there's a lot still to discover even though there's a lot of
papers published already on this, but there's a long way to go.
Okay. So I will stop there and I will hand over to Jacob Kitzman from
the University of Michigan, who's done some wonderful work in the colorectal
field and other areas, and he's going to tell us all about that.
All right, thanks very much, Faris.
Thank you all for coming out.
So my disclosure.
Okay. So I think Faris gave us a really nice overview of sort of the
motivation for why we might want to do large-scale functional
assays, both to
make genetic testing results more actionable,
and also on the research side to learn a bit more about structure and
functional mechanisms. So,
don't want to belabor the point, but
even for genes that are kind of remarkably well-studied and where there's decades
and decades of clinical genetic screening, this is sort of the
bleak landscape of stuff that we know, right?
So this is plotting the missense functional landscape for
MSH2, which of course, is a key
hereditary colorectal cancer and endometrial cancer susceptibility factor.
And I've laid this out now just in the protein
coding regions with the N-terminus at the left, C-terminus at the
right, and then each possible mutant amino acid corresponding to
a row. And so we mined the literature for every
report that we could find, clinical or functional, and sort of
colored each of these different mutations as blue or red according to
what was indicated by those publications.
And basically, everything is unknown, right?
So you can, kind of in a very deeply, intensively studied gene,
you can get about a percent and a half best case
scenario for variants that we know about.
And this is, as I mentioned, not for lack of trying or depth
of knowledge. This is a gene that
was actually the first, I think, familial cancer syndrome gene, has
over 20,000 publications,
accounts for a third of a Nobel Prize, so not too shabby.
So this is a clear bottleneck clinically.
So one thing that we do in the lab, and
many other groups are deeply engaged in, is to develop
enabling technologies to perform MAIVs and to apply those to different
genes. And additionally, one thing that I'll kind of draw a couple
of vignettes, I guess, from here is how do we target different
layers of function? And you can think of MAIVs as applying at different
points across the central dogma. So we and many others have
deployed MAIVs where the goal is to measure regulatory effects.
So now we're taking non-coding variants. We're taking a promoter or enhancer.
We're putting variants into them.
This is often more in the context of common variation.
We're measuring how does that change gene expression activity of a
downstream gene. I'll share a brief example from how we've done this in the context
of mRNA splicing, where we take a MAIV and our readout is specifically telling
us about variant impact upon how a gene is
spliced and not upon protein function.
And then I think I'll focus
most of what I'll tell you about today, kind of looking at MAIVs that
are the target missense variants and where the readout has to
do with the
function of the mutated protein.
So one thing that we've heard about, and I think one thing that's been sort of fun
from a technology development perspective in the field is that there's arisen this
diverse ecosystem of these approaches.
So many different methods for
measuring variant impact at scale.
And kind of four, you can group these along in various
ways and sort of
rank them across different axes, but I've sort of grouped them into four
broad categories here. So deep mutational scanning approaches where you're
taking a cDNA,
so kind of relatively synthetic approach, making lots of
mutations, putting them into cells.
And that's in some sense the most scalable approach in terms of mutational
coverage, right? So we have the ability to entirely saturate
mutational spaces and even do things like address what
are the combinatorial effects of multiple mutations.
So, it's sort of an extreme example, not really clinically relevant.
Groups have made libraries of five, six,
seven variant combinations in GFP to ask how do those affect
its various
properties.
So these are very high throughput in terms of their,
complete in terms of their mutational coverage.
But maybe their scope is not so broad, right?
You can cover a gene's or a couple of
gene's mutational space very deeply, but there's no such thing really as a
genome-wide deep mutational scan.
Kind of at the opposite end of the spectrum, you have something like a pooled base
editing screen where your mutational coverage is much sparser,
often dictated by the activity and capabilities of the base
editor that you're using, but it's relatively straightforward to target
genes across the genome. So you could do a genome-wide dropout screen in base
editors, and a number of groups have done this to great effect.
And then sort of intermediate between these two extremes are saturation genome
editing and a kind of a close relative that's more recent,
saturation prime editing. And these tend to be more
gene-focused,
but perhaps at the cost of maybe having a slightly more restricted
mutational space that they address.
So these are kind of different characteristics of these approaches that the actual
sort of experimental tactics also differ.
So in DMSs, primarily what we and others are doing
are toMake libraries of mutant cDNAs,
and hopefully you have every possible mutation that you want in that library.
Then those are integrated as transgenes, either using lentivirus
or using recombination-based approaches where you're knocking that
construct into a defined target site that's hopefully a single copy
somewhere within a genome.
So some advantages, of course, as I mentioned, is that we get really high
mutational coverage and uniformity with this type of approach.
But the cost is that we do not capture
the endogenous regulatory program that a gene might be under.
We're taking a transgene, we're putting it somewhere else, perhaps in cells that
are knocked out for their endogenous copy.
We've also taken this out as a cDNA.
So we've now specifically focused on
functional impacts at the level of protein function.
So if there are regulatory or splicing impacts, those are just explicitly not
captured here. So, pros and cons.
SGE,
we've won back the ability to capture the endogenous regulatory
program and integrate the effects of these different regulatory layers.
So as for expansion, we could have a missense variant that has lost a function,
but not because
of the amino acid that's been
changed in the protein, but rather because it creates a cryptic splice site, and
that leads to a frame shift or something along those lines.
One disadvantage is that these have been primarily restricted
to haploid cell types, and they take some tuning, so
sometimes the mutational coverage can be a bit lower.
And similar pros and cons apply with saturation prime
editing approaches.
The other thing that we spend a lot of time thinking about when we sit down and
want to deploy a MAVE against a new gene is, what's our functional readout?
What is it that we're actually measuring here?
So
there's lots of different ways to perform selections as
part of these experiments. And really,
we want to
think about this at the front end. So is it protein abundance or, say, localization
that we're interested in measuring?
Can we develop a functional reporter that gives us some sort of proxy for
function that integrates multiple effects?
People have even devised, Dov Haller and others have devised DMSs where the
readout involves imaging and morphology.
The lion's share of these approaches to date, and in particular, the
in situ editing types of approaches, tend to converge on cell viability.
So we're looking at how do mutations change the viability or the
proliferation rate of cells, often by impairing
DNA repair or grossly
dysregulating gene expression.
Okay. So if you want to set out and do a
DMS or a MAVE more broadly, this is your roadmap.
You need a way of making many mutations in a pooled fashion.
Here I'm showing four of them, four different colors.
But of course, in a real experiment, this would be thousands, tens of thousands.
We need to put them in one per cell, impose some sort of selection that's going to
be very dependent upon the function of the gene that you're studying,
and then we read out how those mutations enrich or deplete
across experimental time.
And that comparison of the ending abundance of the four different mutations
versus how they started gives us our proxy for activity, and we
can then calibrate and fit that to give us something that we hope is that we
have some evidence for being clinically meaningful.
Okay, so just as an aside, there's lots of ways that you can make these libraries.
What I'll tell you about today involves taking a cDNA for a given
gene. We split that up into chunks and then
cut out a given chunk, actually using Cas9
in vitro. So we're doing an in vitro digestion with Cas9.
We've got a gene cloned on a plasmid.
We just cut out a given chunk and then replace it with a pool
of oligonucleotides, these rainbow patterns here, in which we've
programmed all of the individual single mutations, or in higher order
screens, we can do pairwise mutations, things of this nature.
And so this gives us very highly uniform libraries, and it costs
about 10% of what it would cost to go to a commercial provider like Twist
or IDT and purchase them.
One other important consideration in the libraries that we do, as well as
MAVEs writ large, is that it's often very
powerful to have
a molecular barcode. And so this concept of molecular barcodes
involves either putting somewhere off target, so
away from where you've made your mutations on a construct that you'll integrate in
the genome, adding either a short random sequence
or what we often do is to add a bunch of silent mutations.
This is, again, in the context of a cDNA-based screen, so we're not worried
that these silent mutations are going to impair
splicing.
But we add these in cis in line with the actual missense mutations that we've made.
So what is this bias? Or equivalently, what is having an
off-site barcode bias? Well, it gives us the ability to
do statistics on the effects that we measure.
So if we don't have a barcode, in the absence of a barcode, we are just counting
using... The sequencer is really just a fancy and expensive counting machine.
We're counting how often do we see a given mutation at the end of the
experiment versus at the beginning.
But really our hope is that that mutation has been integrated independently into
cells thousands or tens of thousands of times. Right?
And so we would really like to have the individual counts of those initial
integration events, and we'd love to be able to track them through the experiment.
But if it's only the mutation of interest that we've made, those are all
identical at the sequence level. Right?
So adding a barcode or adding these inline silent mutations allows us to
track them and do comparisons of distributions, and that can give
us much finer resolution on the scores that we measure.
Okay, so I'll talk a bit about the mismatch repair genes in Lynch syndrome.
Probably doesn't need a ton of introduction to this group, but there are four
core genes in the DNA mismatch repair pathway, the
canonical branch of this pathway.
And loss of function in any one of these four
confers a greatly elevated risk for early onset colorectal and endometrial
cancers. Overall prevalence is thought to beBetween 1
in 270 to 1 in 300. And sort of as a consequence of this
and the variable and relatively late age of onset
for these cancers, there are probably on the order of a million
carriers in the US alone who are unaware of their risk.
Okay. And so, the lion's share then of
variants that cannot be classified clinically and remain in this VUS
pile are missense variants. And so they're again, sort
of similar to the BRCA1, BRCA2
genes.
There are thousands of uncategorized
VUSs and again, these are primarily missense across
these four genes.
So we can test these. How do we do that for mismatch repair genes?
Kind of told you about the generic steps, but one of the key ingredients when
you're setting out to do a MAVE is you've got to have a functional selection that
tells you about the activity of the gene that you want to study.
What's the activity of that protein? Different proteins do different things.
So how do we do this for mismatch repair?
Turns out that mismatch repair is actually, this pathway is
almost without exception dispensable for growth
in culture in vitro, right? So we can culture cells that are knockouts
for any of these four genes, and they will grow at the same rate as their wild type
isogenic controls.
But,
depending on the MMR status in a cell line, this does expose different
sort of synthetic lethalities in vitro.
And the one that we take advantage of is treatment with a purine analog
called 6-thioguanine. And so this treatment with
this base analog is going to specifically kill
cells, sort of counterintuitively, it's going to kill cells that have
intact mismatch repair. So we can treat with 6TG, and this will enrich for
loss of function in that pathway. And then it's just off to the
races with sort of a similar
framework to what you've heard about. We're just flipping the sign.
So when we do these experiments and select with 6TG, the variants that are going to
enrich over the course of selection are going to be those that
are resistant to the 6TG,
and those are loss of function variants.
And those we believe will be the variants that are going to
correlate with pathogenicity.
So in the lab, we've now completed variant to function maps
of
all four of the key MMR genes. Only three would fit on the slide here, but this
adds up to over 73,000 variants. And again, sort
of showing these as a heat map where I've
arrayed them out from one end of the protein to the other.
Each column corresponding to a single codon, each row
corresponding to one of the different 19 mutant
amino acids, and then the wild type, of course, for a total of 20.
And the color of each cell representing the degree of
functional abnormality. So red, more and more red meaning more and more abnormal.
Couple of quality control checks that we do when we're running MAVEs and kind
of standard to do is that you'd expect to see a
strong... Well, not only should you see the truncating variants are
highly abnormal in the assay, and for
a number of reasons, those aren't included in for these genes specifically.
But sort of the next best thing and a great thing to always do is to look at the
proline bar. So you should get a strong ribbon of signal
for loss of function when you make substitutions to
proline within ordered regions of proteins, right?
These are generally highly destabilizing the secondary structure.
And when you look at the proline row, there's a bunch of red.
So that's
hopefully a good sign.
Kind of zooming in, we can
compare to other published functional
assays. So again, sort of standing on the shoulders of giants here because these
genes have been deeply studied. There are lots of functional studies,
sort of more than 100 individual variants that have
been subjected to individual variant
functional studies in the past, and we have excellent concordance.
So here's a known loss of function variant in MLH1, A128
to P. When we zoom in on that on the heat map, we can see that it has a
strongly positive score, and this correlates to
strong loss of function in two previous biochemical assays for MLH1.
The next thing that we, having kind of satisfied ourselves that, yes, our pooled
functional screen is well-aligned with
individual variant assay results that have been previously shown.
We then need to kind of set out and calibrate this to functional data.
And so one key thing that we did here in collaboration with colleagues at Ambry
Genetics was to gather a gold standard set of clinical
variants, and a kind of a critical criterion was that those
clinical variants had to stand, their classifications had to
stand without relying upon functional evidence.
Because functional assays, whether they're pooled or not pooled, tend to work in
similar ways, and so one risk is that we could sort of
have a risk of circularity
if we are validating our functional assay using somebody else's functional assay.
So that kind of works on one level that says that, yes, technically these are
giving us comparable results,
but maybe clinically we might not be able to
place as much weight on that type of calibration.
So we found 48 variants where Ambry's standing
clinical...
48 missense variants in MSH2, what I'm showing here.
Where their standing clinical interpretation didn't depend on functional evidence.
It was based upon family history, tumor characteristics,
MMRD status, et cetera.
And for 47 of those 48 variants, our functional
data agreed directionally with their standing
interpretation. And the one that didn't was actually sort of in the region
that we had defined as being an intermediate.
So that one we sort of set aside and say, "Well, the MAVE result is somewhere in
the middle. We don't know what to make of that.
We're going to exclude it." And so this then meets their various
kind of acceptedStrength of evidence thresholds, which we've heard
about, and this meets the threshold for strong evidence.
And as a result of this,
in one example study, we and colleagues at Ambry were able to go
retrospectively into their database of past test
results and then retrospectively reclassify those,
and this resulted in the return of 10 new
diagnoses of Lynch syndrome to 10 individuals.
We can also look in unselected biobank,
population-scale biobank data. And so this is one example going in the
NIH, All of Us cohort,
where we can look by gene. So I'm showing the four Lynch genes now
where we've performed these variant-to-function maps.
And we're looking, we're asking, again, in an association framework,
if we define all the missense variants that our assays tell us are loss of
function, how does that associate with risk for
colorectal cancer? And we get broadly similar results for endometrial cancer.
And what you can see is this really recapitulates the known pattern where
MLH1 and MSH2 are very high penetrance,
and MSH6 and PMS2 are much lower penetrance.
And we see a very similar pattern, not shown here, for endometrial cancer, with the
exception that MSH6 kind of comes back up.
And this matches what's been seen from large-scale
epidemiology studies of families who are
carriers for truncating pathogenic variants.
So now we're doing this for rare missense variants, ones that might
previously be VUS.
One thing that we often do and
has been, I think, a topic of some interest and some
maybe angst in the field is that we like to compare these results
to the output of computational predictors.
And, of course, this is all a lot of work.
It would be nice if we didn't have to do this work and could just rely on an
algorithm to give us this map and to resolve VUSs.
And it is amazing, these algorithms are getting better and better, but one thing
that we've noticed fairly systematically is that they tend to
over-call missense pathogenicity.
So I'm showing you a chunk of our map for PMS2, or actually, this is the
whole map for PMS2. Where again, blue and white are
functionally normal, red is functionally abnormal.
That's the middle panel here. And at the bottom panel, I'm showing what I think
is widely considered to be one of the best-in-class predictors,
AlphaMissense. And AlphaMissense provides an output which is a
so-called probability of pathogenicity.
And so it provides these scores for every possible missense variant in every gene,
including PMS2.
And just right off the bat, you can see there's a lot more red on the bottom.
So this is not saying that one's right or the other's right, but the
baseline rates of pathogenicity across genes are very
starkly different in the case, at least of this gene.
12% in the case of our MAIV, over 40% in the case of
AlphaMissense.
And so to some extent, this can be, we think, addressed by recalibration, so maybe
setting a different threshold for every gene.
But
perhaps it needs to be done at even a finer scale level.
We might need to go domain by domain, and we can find lots of examples
where there are variants that clinically seem to be
benign just on the basis of how many individuals they've been observed in without a
clear family history.
And in the cases where we can intersect these, we tend to find
that the MAIV sort of seems to agree directionally with
the clinician's interpretation.
So one thing that we're interested in doing going forward is exploring
whether we can use MAIV data to fine-tune or improve
computational predictions.
One thing that I've gotten really interested in recently is
stuff in the middle. So we've heard a bit about hypomorphic or
intermediate variant effects, and these are often--
In the past, we've sort of just set them aside and said, "Well, the MAIV gives us a
score in the middle. We don't want to
be overly aggressive in how we interpret this.
We're just not going to make a prediction about pathogenicity or benignity
if we have this." One reason might be that maybe those scores
are the result of measurement error that's gotten averaged in.
But there are some interesting case studies, I think, some
anecdotal examples in the case of some of the, at least the Lynch syndrome genes,
of variants that really do seem to be hypomorphic and are not
pathogenic on their own,
but
sort of predispose to loss of function that rises to the level of
pathogenic when there's at least a second genetic
hit. And so this is an example from MLH1 with a variant called K618A.
It's relatively common, so we can say with high confidence that it's not
pathogenic for Lynch on its own. But in
families where K618A
co-occurs with a second variant, R659Q,
Lynch syndrome has been observed in multiple unrelated families.
And this other one, this other variant, 659Q, is likewise--
Actually, it's quite rare, but it seems to be functionally normal on its own.
So is there a potential for an interaction between pairs of
variants? And of course, this would be relatively rare in the clinic in an
individual case, sort of squaring things that are rare, but on
aggregate,
maybe not so rare.
So we've set out to do pairwise double mutant screens now, where we make, instead
of making every possible single missense variant by itself,
we now-- Well, we do that, or we've already done that, and then we repeat
that process on the background of something like K618A.
So we're making all these other variants on the background of K618A.
And what I'm showing you here are the loss of function scores, where every dot
corresponds to a rare missense variant.
And I'm showing you the loss of function score on the x-axis where they're made by
themselves.And then on the y-axis, when they co-occur with
K618A. Again, higher score means more
abnormal, more likely to be pathogenic.
So what you can see are there's quite a few missense variants that are benign
by themselves and benign on this K618A background.
There are a lot that are abnormal either way.
There are not any that we can find that are
pathogenic by themselves, but then somehow rescued by K618A.
But what we can find are that there is a substantial minority of missense variants
that are sort of poised for functional abnormality, and
then when they
occur on this background of K618A or
potentially other mildly deleterious variants,
they're sort of pushed down the sledding hill.
Coming from Michigan is the analogy that I like to use.
They're pushed down the sledding hill below a threshold of function that's sort of
critical for pathogenicity. And this
sort of corresponds to this concept of generalized,
nonspecific epistasis, where you have non-additive
effects between pairs of variants.
That's mismatch repair. I'll just say, moving sort of quickly
here, if you want to set up a MAVE for a new gene, again,
you might not have a viability defect when you knock it out in cells.
You might not have a drug that you can use like 6G that provides a
gain of resistance phenotype. So a lot of work, in fact, probably the lion's
share of work in our experience in running these MAVE assays
goes into actually developing or perhaps adapting a previously existing
functional assay and bringing it into this high-throughput
regime. So in one example of this recently, we
adopted a DNA repair assay, a fluorescence readout for
DNA repair to perform a MAVE of the base excision repair gene,
MYH, which is implicated in a common
recessive form of
colorectal cancer,
MYH-associated polyposis. So the way this works is we have a
genetic reporter which contains an 8-OG, an
oxidative lesion,
oxidative damage lesion, which we've placed in a site-specific fashion
within a GFP
plasmid. So in the absence of repair, this is read out,
or there's a stop codon opposite it, and you don't get any
fluorescence.
Only if that lesion is repaired by MYH, do you actually restore
the open reading frame and cells can then take this up and fluoresce, and so you
get a strong GFP signal in wild-type cells, but this is
greatly diminished in cells that are knocked out for this factor.
So we kind of
adapted that existing assay, which has been
developed by a number of groups over the years, and coupled it to this
high-throughput mutagenesis strategy, and then showed that we could do
just that. We could
produce function scores for every possible missense variant in
MYH and actually perfectly
separate nonsense and synonymous variant effects.
And then what we saw was this kind of wide and variable and kind of continuously
varying
spectrum of missense variant effects.
This correlates really well with one-by-one measurements that have been made
in a mutation accumulation assay in bacteria
in the past. This is the heat map.
This was published in "American Journal of Human Genetics" last year.
So you can go and dig this out if you have patient variants.
One thing I'll say is, again, what's going on with these functionally
intermediate variants? They're shown in orange here. Do they matter?
Are they clinically relevant?
It's also not just a few of them. So these are kind of proportionally
almost more than half
as numerous as those that we would say are kind of outright loss of function
comparable to truncating variants.
One nice thing about MYH is that
as a recessive and sort of late onset, relatively low
penetrance disease gene,
that sort of coupled with
the population history here, there are quite a few carriers out in the
population, so we were able to leverage large-scale population data.
There are two founder variants, so
three possible genotypes that are
well-known, so they're relatively common, kind of 0.1%, 0.2%,
0.3% minor allele frequencies.
And it's been well established that G368D is the milder of those.
So if we go into clinical databases, we can see that in fact, yes, the
odds ratio for G368D homozygotes in the light blue
here
is
lower
and the age of onset is later. So we then asked, okay, well, what about
individuals who carry one of these known pathogenic alleles, one of those two
founders
or a truncating allele opposite a variant that we say
is loss of function in our assay? And so that's the red bar there.
And these are very strong risk factors relative to
individuals who carry a loss of function truncating allele and
a missense variant that we say is neutral.
And I think what's interesting and one area where
we're really excited to dig into this more is that the individuals
who carry one of these intermediate variants
opposite a pathogenic variant, they are somewhere down
here. So they're clearly significantly enriched for colorectal
cancers and polyps relative to
neutral variant carriers, but they're not as pathogenic as
outright truncation or the
known founder effects.
So in the last couple of seconds, I'll just say that you could do all these sorts
of things,
but with a readout that doesn't involve protein function, but rather
uses splicing,
which you can measure at scale by RNA-seq.
So we like to hook things up to really scalable
assays.And the basic principle is the same.
We're making libraries of variants.
In this case, we have a barcode coupled to each one, and we can ask by
RNA-seq, does that barcode get properly spliced to an exon that it's
coupled with or does it not?
And this again gives us sort of a continuously variable
map of effects. And so a great number of variants in
many genes have sort of intermediate levels of splicing effect.
We expect to see that variants, again, variants at kind of
canonical acceptors and canonical donors are going to greatly increase
either truncation,
use of some other isoform, or just outright skipping of
an exon. But then there's kind of this large gray area in between.
And I think a lot of work is left to kind of define what those mean
clinically. What does it mean to lose 80% of gene expression, 80% of
proper exon inclusion? Is that enough to sustain gene function
and kind of keep you above the level of function needed
to avoid disease? If you have a lot of data, you
could start learning those thresholds and building classifiers using this sort of
data.
So just to wrap up, kind of
gave a couple of
short vignettes about how we've applied MAIVS in the context
of DNA repair factors that are involved in colorectal and endometrial cancers.
Variant by variant interaction I think is
sort of something that the scale of these assays is
well-matched to inform. And what
we really need in order to apply MAIVS broadly are
functional readouts that are
specific for genes of interest and that are informative as to
the kind of the relative mechanisms that underlie
disease.
Happy to take any questions.
So maybe I can start. I was really interested in your pairwise screens.
That's a really interesting approach.
You show that cluster in the top left-hand corner where it looks like there's a
series of variants that can interact with that one variant.
Yeah.
Do you know how many times they've been seen in patients?
Do you have any clinical data that goes along with that?
Have they been observed in combinations?
Other ones.
I think that this is sort of a known unknown because, in general, you don't
have phasing information.
That's true.
So if they
co-occur within a given exon and you've used NGS and they're sort of within
the span that you can capture both variants on a single read,
then in principle, you can get this phasing information.
But a clinical lab may or may not report it out, and if they
don't or if they're on distant exons such that a given read can't phase together
the two variants, then you don't know if they're
in cis or in trans. And so I think there
aren't great databases
of these in the general case, so...
Thanks. That was really nice.
I thought your comments about benchmarking alpha
missense against the MAIVS was interesting.
Can you comment on whether you think the
apparent overestimation of pathogenicity from alpha missense
is
likely related to a limitation of MAIVS and just
that you're only screening against a single phenotype, and there might be
pathogenicity that's associated with something else?
And is there a kind of principled way that we could go about figuring that out?
Yeah, that's a great question. So,
yeah, in theory, many of the
effect predictors rely on evolutionary signals.
So that's a difference right there.
I think the mismatch repair genes are also involved in different aspects of
meiotic function. So it could be that
across evolutionary timescales,
it's bad to impair those functions, but it's not going to cause cancer in an
individual. That's one possible explanation.
And I think the degree of kind of discrepancy that we see in these genes is
maybe more than is seen in some others.
Kind of the other sort of error mode, if you like, is that
we often see that
the evolutionary-based predictors, they can see that a residue is important,
but they often struggle to sort of be calibrated to
differentiate between mild effects
and really strong effects,
especially in the case of
variants that impair stability.
And so I think that's probably an error on the part of effect predictors.
The one thing I will say is that they're kind of effect predictors, things like
ESM, alpha missense, Verity, things of that nature.
If you just take high-confidence, benign
and pathogenic sort of gold standard, very well-supported
missense variants from ClinVar, for instance, or from clinical labs databases,
the MAIVS and the predictors do often equivalently well at
differentiating those. Where they don't agree is on what's in the intermediate
zone.
Thanks. That's great.
Nice talk.
Thanks.
So my question is also kind of about the pairwise library.
So
unless I misunderstood, so here you're looking at missense variants located close
by, typically within the same exon.
Yeah.
Do you think that seeing missense variants in different exons in
different functional domains of the mismatch repair proteins would show
a similar result?
Yeah, that's a great question. So we will hopefully know relatively soon.
And it may depend. So Mlh1 is interesting because it folds, it has two
independently... folding structured domains.
And so it could be that
they are
maybe buffered against each other somewhat.
So I think there will be some gene by gene variation in
how prevalent and strong this type of
epistatic interaction is.
But I think in general, it's not
super well understood. The other thing in a
cDNA system, the other kind of game you can play is
accepting the caveats that it's artificial because you're putting a
transgene in somewhere. You can sort of turn the knob on expression of that
transgene. So a number of, actually in the case of NEUH, a
number of the missense variants that are damaging to its function are
actually rescuable by just
overexpressing them a lot.
And conversely, a number of variants that are benign in that gene,
if you turn expression down,
they now can't sustain, there's not enough abundance of
the protein
for different mutants to
produce the repair
signal. So I think, context, maybe the takeaway is
it's probably gene specific and context really, really matters.
Genetic context,
are there environmental factors that are changing expression of your mutant, et
cetera?
Thank you.
Yeah. So
I was wondering, so did you say there are double
mutant databases or there aren't? There aren't.
There are not in general. So I think,
in this case, this is a haplotype that's been described
anecdotally in, I think, three or four affected families.
Mm-hmm.
And then
you can sort of scrape these from ClinVar.
The depositing labs will sometimes comment and say, "This variant
co-occurs, and we phased it together on a haplotype with this other
variant." So you can
glean these from
individual ClinVar submission records.
But I guess to my knowledge, there's not a systematic database
of clinical haplotypes. Although, if there is, we'd love to
Yeah. Me too.
Thank you.
Yep.
I want to ask a quick question on the technical end.
Okay.
What do you think is the roadmap to scaling these MAIVs to cover all the
genes in a lot of different contexts?
And what do you see coming in on the technology front that could enable
this to happen?
Yeah. So I think general purpose readouts.
If you have a readout that tells you that
transcription, that gene regulation is perturbed,
that could address a broad swath of genes, transcription factors,
chromatin modifying enzymes. That would
cover a large amount of
rare and maybe common disease space.
There are assays that are fairly generic, so they're
more agnostic to protein function than what I've presented here.
These are very bespoke gene-specific readouts.
They're readouts that tell you about protein stability.
Well, that only gets at part of one slice of the mechanistic pie,
so that's a disadvantage. But the upshot is that
those have been applied across many, many genes.
So I think taking approaches like that that are scalable and applying them broadly,
and then taking this type of bespoke approach and applying it to very high
priority genes where it's really worth the effort to build
gene or pathway specific readouts, that in my mind is the way forward.
So I have a question. Looking at these epistatic interactions,
I'm not sure if my question is valid, but
are the enabler mutations or the second hit
mutations more likely to be within intronic regions or exonic
regions or?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I think that's a really great question.
So in this case, it's two missense variants,
and we think that they're each mildly destabilizing.
So you get
a small hit to folding free energy from each one of them,
and things are nonlinear, so abundance goes down when you have both of
those hits, right? But you could have one variant that's missense and a
little bit destabilizing to the protein, and if that occurs on a
haplotype that has a cryptic splice variant out in an
intron somewhere, that could have a similar effect.
The intronic variant could be reducing your
pool of properly spliced RNA by 50%.
And now on top of that hit, you're taking a stability effect.
So I think there's a need to integrate
different mechanisms, each of which could independently lead to reduction in gene
expression or reduction in function.
But it's a really big mutational space, though.
It's big to start with, and then you're squaring it.
So
I think that's a challenge.
All right, well, thanks everyone.
Thank you all for attending. I hope you found it informative.
Enjoy the rest of the meeting. Okay, bye.